[Music]
hi everyone thanks so much for coming
I am David Ron check p.m. here at Google
working on a project called cube flow
and we're here to talk about how you
bring machine learning to multi cloud
hybrid environments particularly as an
entire stack where it's not just
thinking about the machine learning
workload but the data and all the other
components as well so I always like to
start in this very basic way everyone
has a different idea about what machine
learning is in this case machine
learning starts with a question it
always starts with a question and so you
might take a sample question like how
much is my house worth and then you come
up with some ideas about how you might
think about how you would structure the
answer that question well maybe it's
based on square footage number of
bathrooms location whatever but the U on
one axis you choose that question and on
the second axis that's where you should
choose your house price so in this case
you go out and you collect the data
point well if it's this big it's gonna
be the cost as much money and then you
collect some more data points and then
you collect some more data points and
eventually you get a line you draw this
line and then you answer your question
using all that data in the line you've
collected you say okay I have 2,100
square feet my house is worth
I don't know $339,000 not in San
Francisco of course but you get the idea
so congratulations your machine learning
expert with that you can leave will have
certificates at the door but of course
things get complicated and in this case
you could have things like non-linear
groupings where you have things by
neighborhood or things like that
maybe it's multi-dimensional maybe
things change over time and the reality
is is that that is the essence of
machine learning where that first thing
is clean linear regression you know I
sound very smart among your friends it's
not a line it's a linear regression
machine learning is a way to answer
those questions that you start with
without explicitly knowing how to get
there you you collect a whole bunch of
features and then you ask the system to
come up with an answer for you and at
Google we've done this as well and we
had great
success around this Google obviously
hires some of the best data center
engineers in the world we're very very
proud of how efficient we are we measure
everything in what's called power usage
effectiveness so these are people who
know every linear there is no they're
using renewable power they're using the
latest technology and what they want to
do is they want to be the most efficient
around this electricity to stick all
this electricity in and get the most
amount of compute out and they have a
lot of ideas about what makes a
difference here but what they decided is
well why don't we associate this with
machine learning we'll put all the
features all the data we collect into
the system and see how we can improve
things so what they did it was they they
graphed everything they turned machine
learning on and the graph came down and
then they turned in the Roisin learning
off and it came back up and again these
are the best people in the world who
thought they knew exactly how to make
the system run great and they were able
to get massive improvement by
associating with machine learning so we
say this and we as an industry do a
terrible job around this because we say
this we show off these great signs that
can solve cancer detect heart disease
you know massively improve efficiency
and people say it's great except it's
also very very hard and it's not just
hard because I'm bad at math it is hard
because there's this massive gap most
folks are collecting data and they don't
really know what to do with it or how to
structure in anything like that and then
they want to move over and get to that
ml goodness but there's lots of pain in
the middle and and let me tell you about
what some of that pain looks like the
reason is is because it basically comes
down to this you really today only have
two options when it comes to the rolling
out of machine learning pipeline excuse
me you have do-it-yourself which is
great except you have to setup from
scratch you have to integrate with all
those legacy systems and make sure
things are working properly and
eventually when it comes to migrate
based on your business needs and there's
always a reason to migrate you have to
go and you have to do that all again so
that's a huge pain it does work but it
takes a lot of work or you could go host
it and host it is fine in those first
five minutes but then you have the next
five years you have all of the things
that you had to deal with on the Left
integrating dealing with legacy Plus
hosted a single cloud only
and the reality is as folks are not
single cloud and I'll get to that in a
second and now to be clear that's not
all hosted solutions but it's certainly
the most common situation so haven't
heard we heard this story before and the
reality is we have this was the story
when we first introduced containers and
kubernetes the idea was that everyone
was out there rolling their own bespoke
solutions for rolling out workloads for
doing service discovery having things
componentize and work together but but
that was not efficient it didn't it
things wouldn't work as you moved from
cloud to cloud on Prem
cloud things wouldn't even work within
different zones containers and
kubernetes gave you an explicit
declarative way to roll out your
applications in a way that made sense in
Austin at 2017 we we talked about
kubernetes being this not just a
platform for rolling it out but being
really extensible letting you take
kubernetes and extend it in a way that
makes sense to you and that was the
essence of what we called cloud native
computing using the platform of
kubernetes to extend it in a very
elegant way and so as a result you saw
this huge amount of upkeep actually
uptake of what's called cloud native
apps these declarative highly our micro
service-oriented highly distributed
systems so what we need is cloud native
ml and cloud native ml looks like the
following
it is composable it lets you piece a
number of pieces together based on your
business requirements it's highly
portable it lets you move from place to
place very readily and it's highly
scalable it takes advantage of the fact
that you now have effectively unlimited
compute by this we mean the following so
first composability most folks when they
think about ml they think about starting
with just building a model and that's
true building the model is obviously a
core component but it is just one
component a standard ml pipe Maya might
look much more like this where you're
spending a bunch of time doing data
ingestion and Alice's transformation
then finally you get to your model and
you want to do distributed training and
finally you have to roll it out to
production and an ml system needs to
support all of these things in order to
be production ready second you want it
to be portable
and portable looks like the following
first when you think about your overall
ml or tuna your overall stack of compute
it's obviously not just compute CPU
cycles are just one thing you might have
any of the following associated with it
where that entire pipeline that I
described before is just a portion of
that but multi-cloud is the reality so
you could have this great stack that
looks awesome in one place but 81% of
you are likely to have multiple of these
stacks and not just one multiple stack
in fact the average person has up to
five so what that looks like is where
you have this experimentation workload
running potentially on pram or on your
laptop you might have a completely
different one when you get to training
and a completely different one when you
get to cloud and that now just
multiplies your overall matrices times
three now you might say I know what
you're saying this might not matter to
me you are wrong and I can prove it
in one exercise raise your hand if you
have a laptop congratulations you're all
multi-cloud and don't just trust me
listen to this guy he invented
kubernetes the way I think about it
every difference between dev staging and
prod will eventually result in a
knowledge did you did you catch that
where the me on the delighted for you
you gotta bet dad's dev dev is an
environment dev is a cloud dev is an
environment that you have to replicate
over and over and over again and move
your laptop counts and this column right
here tends to be the one that is your
experimentation and it is something that
when you when your data scientists are
working on their experiment and they go
to their production scientist and they
say all right it's time for you to run
this model they're like I can't use any
of the stuff that you ran and that's not
good and then finally when we think
about scalability we think about all of
these things now many people just say
okay it's just
GPUs TPU CPUs but it really scalability
as human beings and it's skillsets and
it's number of experiments you need a
system that can handle all of these
things so cloud native ml composable
portable and scalable you know what's
really good at these things
containers and kubernetes except of
course if you want to use ml and
kubernetes today you have to become an
expert
in many many things and that's not good
so that's why in December of 2017 we
introduced cube flow cube flow is our
goal is to make it easy for everyone to
develop deploy and manage portable
distributed ml on kubernetes and so what
this looks like is you use kubernetes as
the unified layer it works on your
laptop via mini cube dr. EE it works on
the cloud it works on your training
environment we have a cube flow
deployment that works that describes
your entire pipeline and then you're
able to stamp out that exact same cube
flow deployment in multiple locations
right now in the Box we are just at 0.1
but we have a jupiter notebook we have
distributed training we have multi model
framework we have lots of examples and
best of all we use a tool developed by
hep tio called case Annette which lets
you customize for your own packages
including private packages that are
relevant just for yourself in the box
today we have this which includes a
trainer a model model validation
training at scale and then also serving
in monitoring and with that I'd like to
show you a quick demo of what it looks
like to roll out a cube flow so here we
are we're gonna do a getting started and
I'm gonna use something this is a real
live demo but it types for me so I can
talk while I do it so the first thing
we're gonna do is we're actually gonna
start an azure I spun up at kubernetes
cluster last night it's ready to go we
switch contacts to act as her and now
we're gonna introduce our new cube flow
app you see there I just hide kick
KS that's case Annette in it and it
created the directory I switch into the
directory and now I'm switching over to
the context I create my brand-new
environment locally and I say hey just
letting you know we're gonna deploy to
Azure we set the parameter telling cube
flow that you're deploying to that that
environment I just set up and now we're
gonna select the things that matter
right so the first thing I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna add that registry there's just
a cube flow registry out there it's
public I'm gonna install core in there
it's going to go and download 33
different files it's going to install
Agro which is our workflow engine that's
built-in and it's gonna install TF
serving and again this is really really
straightforward I'm just selecting
whatever makes sense to me for my
particular environment I generate the
deployment and I roll it out that's it
I just deployed an entire ml pipeline or
accidently it'll deploy momentarily an
entire ml pipeline to this kubernetes
cluster running on Azure and it's taking
a little bit of time I apologize the
network but you can see here it's
rolling out all these various services
it's rolling out a dashboard it's
rolling out a TF job operator which
extends the kubernetes api is rolling
out ambassador as a reverse proxy it has
a stateful set to maintain your
workloads across various runs and so on
so now just to prove that it's actually
running there you can see that on cube
control I get that now let's do the same
thing so now I've done this imagine that
you know I had my training cluster on
Azure because that's where we had some
particular data I want to replicate that
except now I want to do on an AWS and in
this case all I need to do is I need to
switch that I need to create a new
environment for AWS I set the parameter
that I'm deploying to as being a be W
yes and there you go that's it same
exact thing now running over on AWS and
again it'll take just a second here to
roll out this is in fact running live no
videos or anything like that not that
there's anything wrong with videos and
as that rolls out
we will let's actually go and prove to
you that is in fact running here you are
this is the Jupiter notebook
Jupiter is basically the data science
environment and if I was a data
scientist I would have executed that one
command which you know they're already
familiar with how to do very basic
installs like that through things like
pip and in this Jupiter notebook that I
have running here you can see it's just
a regular old Jupiter notebook I'm gonna
train on this and train my model and I
get an output again very very
straightforward I deployed this all in
one single command
and finally we're going to do the exact
same thing except we're gonna do it to
gke so again I switch it very very
quickly and roll it out again now three
different clouds one command all I did
was switch the environments it knew how
to pick it up and roll it out to these
various locations and you can see as it
picks it up here here again nothing
nothing happening and I hit refresh on
the workloads and you start to see them
rolled out so again
integrated with the underlying platform
so that easy
that's simple I able to just select the
packages that make sense to me and move
on so as I said that's only one
component of an end-to-end machine
working workload you you want to choose
all these components but you need to go
with the data and the reality is data
needs portability as well
q Burnett ease and cube flow we give you
AB portability but you need data
portability around you know where you're
using and consuming that environment how
you share that between the various
locations how you make it usable to both
cloud native and legacy apps and then
filing how you scale that on demand and
with that I'd like to hand off to my
colleague who will tell you all about
Alaska file and its portability thank
you David
so I'm a long coin from Alaska file and
what I'm here to tell you is that at the
end of the day your models are just as
good as the data you place into them and
that data is actually being created
everywhere it's been created in data
centers on premises it's being created
at the edge you need to package that
data you need to bring that data to
where you can process it and after you
process it and create those models you
need to take them and bring them back to
the edge to where you can use them for
predictions and for fighting out what
this machine learning thing can really
do for you in practice so alas the file
is just that platform that matches those
needs of the data for these machine
learning environments we provide data
mobility to bring the data to where it's
needed
we provide shareability so that the
applications creating the data on Prem
can use the same data platform that cube
flow in tensor flow in general uses to
process that data we provide usability
to make this all simple for the end-user
and we provide scalability so you can do
that training and you can process that
data as fast as you can and obviously in
the cloud as in anywhere else time is
money
how do we do that we do that with two
basic platforms we have our last e-file
cloud file system which is a scale out
software only POSIX compliant file
system and we have Cloud Connect which
is a system that allows you to move the
data into the cloud and between a file
and an object layer the elastic file
cloud file system is as mentioned
posix-compliant
meaning you can mount it as an NFS mount
as an SMB mount to any application that
uses files and what applications doesn't
use files it's scalable you can go to
the petabytes you can go to the tens of
gigabytes in throughput per second and
it has a full Enterprise ready feature
set including snapshots data repair a
data reduction replication across
environments as we will show you you can
control it through a GUI or you can even
automate the whole process that we'll be
demoing it you to you today through rest
api's controls and it's available
immediately at Google through the Google
marketplace as we will also demonstrate
in our data in our demo so elastic file
crosses all those persistent storage
needs of kubernetes environments and
cube flow in particular in these
environments the usability the
scalability the share ability and the
data mobility now we actually prepared a
great demo for you this was a medic
demo it involved the medical researcher
sitting in hospital collecting data that
medical researcher transferred the data
to an AI company that did the research
and the model creation in the Google
environment and the result was
transferred back to different Hospital
locations so that the people using this
data doctors offices can find out
through the model where there are
certain disease is what they thought it
was but unfortunately our marketing
department got a look at this demo and
they said no way you're not showing
images of diseases up here on the system
we said we still want it to be life
sciences so they said okay life sciences
marketing use flowers so the demo I'll
show you uses flowers it will use a
botanist that is doing their research
and a model that identifies flowers but
whenever I say but amidst think of a
medical researcher and whenever I say
florist think of a doctor sitting in his
office so with that we'll go to the demo
itself I'm going to show you five simple
steps the first two steps are
preparatory steps they need to be done
once the first thing you're doing to do
is to get the last two file as I said
that's very simple you saw how simple it
was to deploy a cube flow and the last
file is just as simple you can do it
directly through the Google marketplace
we're showing you going to the
marketplace and deploying the elastic
file platform as noted it's a
software-only platform so it deploys
anywhere any region any zone wherever
you can run a VM in the Google
environment or in Amazon or in Azure as
shown you can run elastic file and the
deployment is as simple as what you saw
you can go into the administration and
actually create new data but what we'll
show you is something much
cooller will show you data that is
already available on Prem being
replicated to this environment so here
is our botanist sitting in his medical
research environment and we're using
WordPress here just to show an
application working in a regular
environment and what this botanist is
doing is he's category izing different
types of flowers putting them in
different buckets and he has a regular
application it's actually also a
container but as a regular application
it simply has a place where it's storing
its data in this case the place where
it's storing his data is a provision
volume from elastic file simply
provisioned as NFS for the data mobility
aspect so the first part is a wordpress
working with data that is sitting in a
file system in this case it's elastic
file but actually it can be in any file
system sitting in your environment and
what we're going to do is we're going to
tell the system to replicate it into the
cloud and we're going to do this
replication not as a one-time thing but
actually is something that is repetitive
because whenever this researcher or the
50 other researchers gathers new data we
want that data to go to the cloud so we
simply go to the elastic file GUI we
define a replication in this case five
minutes will also retain two snapshots
but you can essentially retain as many
snapshots as you want submit that for
connection and within these five minutes
we have a complete set up which has
elastic file running across the
environments and data being replicated
now these data containers can be
exported as NFS so if we exported it as
NFS to WordPress in one location we can
very simply now export it in
Google cloud so we're going to start the
fun this is our botanist researching up
I don't know if you caught that but he
just found a new malignant flower and
this is something that he wants to
categorize and put it in the system and
as you can see he's simply using his own
application again in this example
WordPress and he's going to use that
application to identify this new flower
it's a rose it's a new type of rose that
was unknown to the field before and he
just added it to his data now oh that
would have been useless if it was just
sitting inside his button area inside
his lab but as you recall we have set up
the system so that automatically
whenever new data is created that data
is being shipped to the Google cloud
environment so as you will see because
we are replicating every five minutes
essentially immediately that data is
available the system makes sure that it
is only replicating the new data so that
you're not wasting throughput in either
direction it identified that there is no
new data it moved that data into an
elastic file provisioned data container
inside the cloud and we can simply mount
that data container using NFS and we see
that all of the new images that were
used by our researchers have been
immediately brought up to the Google
environment so that if a new training is
being done and if we want to improve our
model all of the new data is available
there so that is exactly what we'll do
now and the beauty of containerized
environments is that connecting them to
a distributed file systems such as
elastic file is a very simple thing to
do and where you're going to use the
capabilities of cube
floo and very simply now within the
Google environment create new
provisioned volumes and we're going to
show you that just as you can provision
volumes from local storage which is not
scalable
you can provision volumes from an NFS
mount such as elastic file which is
scalable and we can be accessed by as
many parts as you need
simply because NFS provides a multi
reader multi writer capability into
these environments and in the case of
elastic file also scalable and available
across different environments so now all
that's essentially left for us to do is
to run tensorflow
on the data that we have exposed inside
a Google and we're going to simply look
at the JSON net and show you that we
defined the data as being sourced from
the new elastic file provisioned volumes
we are also adding a new volume and that
volume is essentially where we'll take
the resulting model it's called here
train out the train out model will also
be placed on an elastic file data
containers because as you will see
shortly we want to then use that data in
different environments we have
everything set up and we're simply going
to run the model but before doing that
we'll just show you that there's nothing
inside the TF out right now because we
haven't run it just yet but we will and
running it is a simple command of
executing encase on it applying the TF
job that we've just created we write
apply and we apply it and a job is
create
we can grab that job and see it's up
here for the 11 seconds that we just ran
it we can see that the pod is being
created in our kubernetes a cluster and
this is a small demo so we're using one
pod but essentially as kubernetes can
grow the number of pods elastic file can
grow in the back and the storage side
and handle as much bandwidth as as much
a ops as you would need in the
environment we'll take a look and see
that this is running you can either look
at the logs or use the beautiful goo is
provided through cube flow it is indeed
running you can monitor either flow API
or further through the GUI the data
being used over elastic file in this
case as we said it's a very small demo
but again the elastic file environment
can grow to millions of AI ops in tens
of gigabytes per second because you do
want to complete this training as fast
as possible and all of this training is
happening on the very latest data that
appeared in the cloud we just completed
updating the model and again it's very
nice that we have a new model but we
want to take that model to where it's
useful so we're going to do just as we
did before a replication this time of
the TF out volume taking the results and
replicating it into a third environment
this can be another region in Google
this can be back to on-prem this can be
anywhere with two clicks we are
replicating our model and this makes
sure because it's a synchronous
replication that's constantly happening
that the model users have the very laced
mod like this model and the model as you
recall has the very latest data NFS
again so no matter what your application
is that is going to run this model you
can simply make a new directory this
time the director we will be from GCP
because we transferred the data from GC
p and we can mount our NFS volume into
that directory and once we mounted this
volume that was replicated we are
assured that the data is available for
our processes wherever we're going to
run them and this can be an IOT
environment and this can be multiple
environments where we send that model to
and there is our model and data and our
florists just saw this horrible
malignant flower in one of these
patients and is going to check whether
that is indeed a rose and in this case
we're running a simple Python script
that uses the model to do a prediction
and with 99% we're assured that this is
a rose because the model that we're
using was retrained on the very latest
data in the field so there you have it a
storage platform that enables you to
complement all of the cross cloud
capabilities and cross environment
capabilities of cube flow and Tenzer
flow back to you David so as you can see
cube flow truly is portable and it
supports all of the portability of
something just like a last file to help
you move your data as well but this is
GCP next if we were just doing Q flow
10.1 that's not interesting let's do
something cooler let's introduce Q flow
0.2 and Q flow 0.2 takes all the work
that we've done up to date and extends
it even further so some of these are new
and improved components with some really
advanced stuff I'll be showing you in
just a second platform integrations
specifically taking advantage of
different clouds that we deploy to and a
much simplified getting started
experience
so advanced features one of the things
that we really wanted to do when it came
to
Flo was making a platform we didn't just
want to be providing all of these
solutions we wanted to let you pick and
choose plot platform components that
came from outside that came from other
companies in this case h2o
they had a great demo yesterday if you
didn't weren't there you can watch it
online but basically they're using cube
flow to take care of a lot of the core
components and then they're
differentiating and it looks like this
basically where you have a CPU that's
provided underneath you have kubernetes
and cube flow as a layer on top of that
and then you're able to distribute the
unique components of h2o both the close
source and the open source version to
run on top of it and then people can
build and engage at that higher level
they never even have to think about what
they're running on that's part of the
essence of what we provide with cube
flow second we have a hyper parameter
tuner for those that don't know one of
the most complicating and annoying
things about building a model is really
tuning your hyper parameters how big
your batch is how many epics you should
run what your target should be in things
like that in cube flow right now we have
a brand new alpha component called cat
tip which is based on the same work that
we do at Google around hyper parameter
tuning it's an open-source version and
it's all checked in and you can see here
this is just a gif of running through
how you might experiment in a whole
variety of ways directly inside cube
flow to explore the most efficient hyper
parameters for your system and then
finally we want to talk about PI torch a
lot of people can make the assumption
that cube flow means tensorflow only
that flow really means machine learning
flow and we really are deeply committed
to many many different frameworks we
want to make it very explicit here PI
torch is absolutely some supported it's
in alpha right now and we expect to hit
beta very soon and to swap it out here
where those steps that you saw earlier
to swap it out you literally say I'm
gonna cross that out I'm gonna swap in
presto you're now using PI torch second
I want to talk about platform
integrations so one of the things you
saw with Alaska file is that Alaska file
just did the work under the hood it just
surfaced a persistent volume claim
to kubernetes and cube flow knew how to
use that and that's something that's
very fundamental to cube flow we don't
want to do the work to you know think
about your various clouds
you know this cloud has a and this cloud
has B that's great as long as you
surface those elements to kubernetes
we're good and for that it looks
something like this we want to support
the the things that are specific to your
cloud around security data exfiltration
prevention identity aware proxy second
we want to support a unique cloud
specific infrastructure maybe FPGA GPU
TPU things like preemptable VMs and then
finally kubernetes extensions where
people don't fork kubernetes but they
take advantage of the extensibility of
kubernetes to take advantage or to
provide unique problems to our solutions
for their customers think these would be
things like node pools and auto scaling
clusters now to be clear cube flow
already supports all of these today we
do it right now on gke
but there's nothing specific about cube
flow and gke it just happens that the
gke team saw the this opportunity and
built a number of solutions and
connectivity for us this is absolutely
supported anywhere that kubernetes is
compliant specifically i want to call
out two things first TPU acceleration
TPU is google's um tensor processing
unit it's designed to make processing
machine workloads very very fast and in
this case an example is around using a
number of image processing it before on
a number of TP use you might get through
about 900,000 images per second and with
TP use it's almost twice as fast at 1.7
million
similarly cost to reach accuracy when
you're doing machine learning workloads
you're your number one goal is to reach
accuracy and in this case to reach 75
percent accuracy total dollars when
you're running on non GPUs is about 129
bucks on GPUs it's less than half as
much $55
so both faster and a lower price second
auto scaling clusters this is the
probably the number one thing that we
hear when it comes to machine
learning learning workloads data
scientists know data they understand
what their needs are but they don't want
to think about infrastructure at all and
so an example here is my model works
great the data scientist says I want six
nodes so they asked their IT ops person
to do it but their idea person has a lot
of things to do and that's not great
she's very patient but finally she goes
the IT ops person goes distributes it
creates us six nodes and passes it back
to the data scientist execute days
scientist does her work and then she's
done she walks away she says great I'm
on to my next problem unfortunately they
forgot to turn it off and that's lots of
money and that's not great again this is
something where you have two different
people working in two different ways and
what you really want is to let the data
scientists describe what happens and let
kubernetes take care of the rest so
that's where we get to auto-scaling
tensorflow jobs the the data scientist
describes what they need CPU RAM
accelerators and so on the TPU jobs then
provision themselves and by the way they
delete themselves when they're done and
scale back down please do remember to
save your logs externally to that and
then finally they cap based on maximum
scale parameters so your you know your
data scientist can't go and say I want
10,000 nodes and so what that looks like
is this the data scientist goes and they
say okay I'm ready to roll out my job
here it is this is a brief abbreviated
version I'll show you what a real one
looks like in just a second they say I
want six I want one CPU I want one
GPU for each of the nodes and here's the
container to go and run kubernetes auto
provisions that including attaching the
GPUs jobs done nodes delete themselves
and the IT ops person finds out cool
stuff about YouTube during they all that
process actually I do a person are going
and working on really hard things
they're just not dealing with us things
that the data sign kids didn't take care
of themselves so with that let me demo
it for you really quickly okay so we
will pop over here so here you are this
is the Y amyl that you might use for an
auto scaling Koster it looks like this
like I said it's
this is literally all it's required and
what we'll do is you can see here I want
six replicas I want CPU and a GPU and we
will get nodes and you can see here I
just have three nodes control create a
chef and I'm going to create my training
that's it the data scientist has now
submitted her job to the cluster and the
clusters go and gonna go and create it
now I'm gonna show you this and you're
gonna say wait where are the nodes well
the problem is is that it takes about a
minute you don't want wide-ranging nodes
spin-up and spin-down so what we'll do
is we'll get the pods and I will show
you that you can see here they are all
created all six are created and they're
pending and we will describe the pod and
you will see here at the bottom it says
insufficient so what I'd like to do is
let's swap back and we'll come back and
check in on this in a second because
we'll do another demo in second okay and
then finally we want to do simplified
setup so you saw there you know I know
that's just six total commands for
setting up cube flow but that's boring
and terrible who would want to do six
commands how about one say your version
to download a script in this case
deployed SSH and if you already have it
on your system you don't even need to
redo it three you deploy great right
here now you're at one command so one
command is better than six even I know
that
so let's swap over and I'll show you
what that looks like and let's see how
we're doing here we get our nodes and
it's still coming up we'll come back to
that in a second
oops and here we are easy setup LS and
in this case we are going to I left some
old stuff here so we'll just get rid of
you alright so you can see here deploy
Sh
this is a lot of stuff but really you
know it's it's pretty straightforward it
you know
ask for your IP address and things like
that but this is the important part that
you're gonna want to care about so you
can detail right there in your deployed
SSH the packages that you want but
everything else is taken care of for you
and in this case I want to deploy it all
so I've downloaded it already and it's
done that's it everything that you saw
before is now being set up as we speak
and that is exactly what our intention
was to make it that easy to set up cube
flow over time and let's go back to see
what our node situation is and you can
see there oh so it has been provisioned
and it's just a matter of coming up and
attaching to the kubernetes cluster so
but you can see there we had the the
nodes that we had originally and then we
added those six that were specific to
the particular workload so that's tube
flow that is what what we're working on
to make machine learning on communities
easy you didn't see bespoke solutions
you didn't see us having to extend
kubernetes or fork it in some specific
way you also didn't see cloud specific
tech everything you saw there is surface
to kubernetes through standard extension
points and that really is key and you
didn't see forking of the kubernetes api
the kubernetes see RDS are designed for
this kind of extension and are
absolutely critical for what we use
we've had great momentum since we got
started over a thousand commits a
hundred contribute community
contributors 20 plus companies
contributing including very very
significant folks KY cloud Alibaba Cisco
obviously Google uber contributed MPI
and [ __ ] Avadh we have pachyderm for
doing data processing and you can see
many of the other folks there and the
reality is is that this is what we're
trying to do as you saw our goal is to
get to a place where data scientists can
operate at that next layer up they
shouldn't have to understand anything
about their underlying infrastructure
they should focus on the work that
they're trying to do because they're
experts at that they're not experts in
infrastructure and it is absolutely our
goal that within I don't know five years
every paper in the world every research
every experiment in the world
comes with a cube flow deployment a
pipeline that describes how to run that
model and and deploy for all the way
from data all the way out to production
and sample data and with those three we
think we can make dramatic improvements
to the overall reproducibility problem
and really our goal is to empower these
the people not here the people who don't
know anything about kubernetes we want
to give them tools to make their own
decisions with their own data and we are
just getting started
cube flow 0.3 is doing weeks where weeks
is about 12-hour roadmap you know we're
really marching through getting towards
a 1.0 and we want to bring a lot of
those alpha features that you saw
forward into beta but also we want to
make again keep pushing higher-level
that hyper parameter tuning right now it
requires a little bit of code our hope
is that we can accomplish that without
any code whatsoever we want to provide
job operators right now just for pi
torch it was a little bit of work but we
want to support all the frameworks extra
boost and cafe and MX net and all those
various things and we're going to do
that through a standard extensible
framework and then finally we want to
get to things like click to deploy again
data scientists shouldn't even have to
see code they shouldn't even have to use
a deploy script they should be able to
do that behind the scenes or better yet
tell us because we really are listening
it is a wide open community we want to
respond to wherever you're taking it and
the more scenarios that you come up with
the better it is and it'll help guide
the project and with that there's lots
of places to connect please reach out to
me reach out to a last of I'll reach out
wherever you'd like because we really
are ready to hear about how you'd like
to use this and bring it to medium
[Music]